A robot designed to scratch your itch? Oh,
and here's a palm laser so that you can be like
Iron Man.
VSauce, Kevin here. This is Mind Blow.
A multi-touch LCD wall was rigged to play
Fleet Commander - a real-time strategy game
developed at the electronic visualization
laboratory. It's a Star Wars game and watching
these kids play it reminds me of Ender's Game.
Watching this Tetris Master reminds me never
to think I'm good at Tetris again.
And watching this might make you barf. It's
the steepest RollerCoaster in the world. It's
located in Japan and has a 43 meter drop with
a 121 degree freefall.
To cool off after the ride visit the Japanese
Frozen Aquarium. It showcases 450 specimens
of marine life frozen in ice and illuminated
with blue light.
"Hey, I'm wearing an episode of the Simpsons."
You certainly are, sir. You certainly are.
The world's largest photo is on display at
the Culver Center of the Arts. The 32x111
foot photo was taken with the world's largest
camera... Which is an abandoned aircraft hangar
with a 6mm hole in the side that functions
as the aperture.
Perhaps the most complicated way to take a
photo is with this Rube Goldberg machine.
It took about 6 months to put together but
the results are well worth it...Check it out...
After all that work, relax in the Hammock
House. It's a five story hangout spot in Vienna
meant to serve as an oasis of relaxation.
And outside of it is umm..this...
Here's some levitating water. It's not a video
effect. This real, steady stream of water
has a strobe effect on it to make it look
like individual floating droplets.
And this is Flashed Face Distortion Effect.
The pictures of these women are not altered
in any way. But if you stare at the cross in the middle
as the faces flash, their images appear to
stretch and distort in a freakish manner.
Finally, an
epic animation referred to as Little Nemo,
from exactly 100 years ago.
I'm gonna leave you with
a riddle.
There are two animation and three video game
references in this video. The first person
to name them all will be our genius
of the week. So good luck and, as always,
thanks for watching.